c'est tout de suite les bois boîte avec
mon ami ryan benetti qui nous a rejoint
mon ryan c'est magnifique on sait qu est
ce un anniversaire en plus à ryan
benetti salut mon ryan d'amour comment
savoir
merci mon chéri tu es magnifique tu es
beau tu es beau ayant elias endroit qui
est avec nous merci qui va jouer avec
nos bois ouate salut sandra merci
cendres avec la merci avec celle qu'on
embrasse moi ça lui déchirer vous nous
appelez dont la famille a pedu les
séries les chéris vous nous a pedu
sandra d'accord très bien ma chérie bas
merci d'être là y'a ryan benz étiquette
avec le également été magnifiques fleurs
est très très très beau bravo
franchement bravo pour la personne
bravo pour la personne on va jouer pour
50000 euros
les cherry et on va jouer pour les
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
avec sandra et avec ryan les chéris il y
à une boîte à 50000 euros il ya une
boîte a dit me dubois ta salive ou voilà
ça sent une boîte à sons et bien sûr il
ya des cadeaux un petit peu moins bien
c'est parti vous choisissez quelle boîte
ragga et s'embrassent la boîte numéro 4
la boîte ne s'attend à rien de la boîte
pliante way est très bien très bien
la boîte numéro 4 c'est la boîte avec
gilles verdez donc c'est votre boîte
vous garderez cette loi de peut-être
jusqu'à la fin allez on va les y à un
dinar algérien oui mon cher et il a agi
allez c'est parti on y va ma sandra
élimine tout de suite une première boîte
tu peux demander l'avis de rihanna tu
joues avec ryan aller oui kate comme
pour éliminer écoute regarde c'est le 9
avril va si on enlève le nas
alors on enlève le 9 on enlève la boîte
numéro 9 tout de suite c'est la boîte
avec maxime galy mon maxime gainey est
ce qu'il y a une belle somme
derrière maxime daigneault jo boiboite
je sais que vous attendez ce jeu tous
les soirs que vous soyez en famille et
les enfants les parents bien sûr c'est
un dérivé un linge et au goût ps est
bien scellé boiboite de baba et j'espère
peut-être qu'à la rentrée on fera le
vrai joue les cherry et bien ryan
whitney a choisi la boîte numéro 9 c'est
de quelle origine ryan ryan tu as enlevé
le dinar algérien mon chéri du super
super super le dinar algérien
j'avais une très très bonne boîte bravo
mont royal
allez on en enlève une deuxième tout de
suite on entend les 22e tout de suite si
je te laisse faire ok alors le neuf
tu peux toujours sur la deux allez ryan
la deux
la deux c'est la boîte avec ma valérie
bénaïm qu'on embrasse les chéris on
continue c'est les bois boîte de baba
qu'y at-il dans la boîte numéro de
quelle somme va t'on éliminer ou quel
cadeau pourri va-t-on illuminé et bien
du mois de septembre on sait bien
le poivron rouge normande brian et bravo
à sandra magnifique
sandra et ryan pour l'instant ça se
passe très bien allez on dit ça va
obliger le droite on vise la babouche
droite maintenant on va on va taper dans
s'ils savaient très bien pour vous allez
le 6 le fils la boîte numéro 6 et kelly
kelly kelly v de v li qui a fait la
boîte à 50000 euros il ya deux jours est
ce qu'aujourd'hui elle a une grosse
somme qu'il y aie aie aie aie aie aie
aie aie aie
vous perdez la trottinette électrique
oui bah oui ça va ça va ça soit bien ça
passe très très bien pour l'instant
vous avez enlevé que des cadeaux rit ça
se fasse chez p1 et merzoug blanchard
notre charcutier trader est avec nous
pour nous faire une petite proposition
déjà comme tu peux le voir merzouk pour
l'instant ça se passe très très bien
pour eux donc intérêt à faire une très
très belle proposition
alors pas de menaces m'a dit je te ferai
jamais de mal à l'atp bon que vous
propose 700 euros 700 euros tout de
suite sandra h70 sandra avec les sommes
qu'il ya 700 euros en essence non pas
pour l'étude cendrars accroché lui alors
accroché mais là c'est pas possible
merci
sandra keith avec toute sa famille fait
quoi dans la descendre à 1 mois je suis
inspire aux patients d'accord mon mari
travaille à lille
ah bah écoutez mon coin du feu un gros
bisou la vue j'ai vu qu'il allait
s'occuper de la famille combien
d'enfants rire et coo chez les filles
quatre enfants atteints des jumelles en
fait vous leur faites de gros bisous les
cherry et j'espère qu'ils allaient
remporter une belle somme pour eux et
pour tout votre si on continue pour
l'instant ça se passe très très bien et
je vous le dis vous êtes ravissante à
l'antenne voilà oh merci là franchement
voilà et vous embrassez votre mari david
a beaucoup de chance ou l'élite
voilà il reste il a intérêt à rester
confinés celui-là il a terra cota
aah oliva on élimine une nouvelle boîte
c'est parti les stèles à une lan on
enlève la une à les numéros y a une
c'est benjamin castaldi là une allée
castaldo ch est-ce que c'est du bon pour
l'instant ça se passe très très bien si
vous nous rejoignez ce jeu des boîtes il
ya toujours 50 mille euros douro 5000
euros à gagner
ah bon ça va ça va on perd 100 euros
sarr ok ok ok ça va ok c'est mieux c'est
c'est mieux que le reste c'est la plus
petite somme que vous avez enlevé ça va
aller mal sans drame on enlève tout une
deuxième boîte un mot nazi phase i man
l'a12 l'a12 l'a12 à bernard montiel et
ouais j'espère qu'on va pas enlever en
plein soleil
salehi c'est sûr qu'ils aient chirila
groupe i la grotte bernard montiel qu'on
aime bernard montiel qu'on chérit
bernard montiel qu'on kiffe allez on
ouvre bernard maury
vous aimez bernard montiel son bras oui
t'as réfléchir comment elle à réfléchir
quiche aux vers la rochelle bernard
montiel sandra va rester un très très
mauvais souvenir pour vous j'étais sur
la boîte numéro 12
sandra à l'asam en béton
[Musique]
58 euros bon c'est pas de la faute de
bernard mais non on l'écouté pour
l'instant il nous restait dix mille
euros ce serait formidable hymne il fait
un mille euros tu fais quand même
formidable donc les chéris on oublie on
oublie et on se remet tout de suite on
enlève une troisième mois de suite alors
ryan ryan je souris à la main
je sens qu'à la maman ryan vas-y on va
on va partir sur du 14 du 14 allée du 14
sophie cost
tout de suite là il faut repartir
faudrait éliminer pourrait qu'on élimine
aux pois chiches la boîte de pois
chiches
[Applaudissements]
houba bush
ah là là là on est bien démarrer là là
s'installant ça se gâte les chéris là je
suis embêté un acheteur sentais bien
cela vaut aussi en vue je sais pas s'il
ya dans les boîtes un jour il dit mais
là 5000 euros on conserve quand même on
a toujours les 10000 aller il ya les
redoublants car qui va nous faire une
proposition merzouk quelle est la
proposition du banquet sachant qu'on n'a
plus les 50000 et qu'on a plus les
syndics il nous reste trois belles
sommes quand même dix mille 1000 et 5000
euros
et après il nous reste 1 2 3 4 5 6
cadeaux beaucoup moins bien alors merci
alors je vous propose tout d'abord je
les anniversaires ryan
merci et je vous propose 1200 euros 1200
euros à ceux ci semblent pour vous six
ans pour les hôpitaux
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal venu pour
jouer donc adam et jouait donc sandra
veut jouer jusqu'au bout elle refuse
votre proposition à 1200 euros bouder
merci c'était une belle somme
j'espère qu'on va pas la rue des allées
on enlève trois nouvelles boîtes c'est
parti c'est parti et sandra et ryan si
vous nous rejoignez ces jeux des bois
bois toujours police de paris hôpitaux
de france et pour racketter avec la
caisse alors la carte aller il ya le il
ya le mari qui revenue il a dit je vais
prendre l'affairé en main
il a neigé prendre la faire en moins la
salle c'est là qu'un c'est jimmy mohamen
et on enlève un plus tôt voyez vous à
pourrait sur le thème magnifique cité
s'appelle comment votre mari sandra
tonye tonye bateau ni bravo tu as bien
choisi montoni bravo allez on en a aussi
banni j'ai continué à tenir à lettonie
ancienne enchaîne trois mois tenait en
chercher un pigment entraîné le bois ps
place allez il reste à la 13e place à 5
à 3 l'a11 l'habiter l'a10 la scène déjà
le nazi ans les glaciers
cette année la toile est la fête la fête
jean michel lair allez on enlève la cei
centrale est une tablette c'est bien
établie non allez on enlève la tablette
c'est très bien bon allez on considère
pour l'instant le dily noro et les 1000
euros
allez on en avait un troisième point
d'aller à 13 l'a13 l'a13 et chevet
qu.aller la tresse doc gynéco aller il
ya tenu qu'ils ont enlevés doc gynéco la
la ce a enchaîné on enchaîné les belles
performances et on est pas mal du tout
là on a on a repris du poil de la bête
avec tonic est arrivé tony l'a dit
rooney mais moi ça jure prendra en main
pour vous pousser c'est moi le tholy bon
alors les chéris il nous reste toujours
la boîte à 10000 euros la boîte a mis la
boîte à 500 je crois qu'il mérite mon
cher qu'il va nous faire une proposition
merzouk merzouk blanchard est avec nous
mais résout qu est ce que tu peux nous
faire une proposition est une belle il
nous reste toujours dit 1000 1500 et
nous reste trois cadeaux moins bien
centrale vapeur boîte de prod chiches et
une babouche droite en tout cas bravo un
taudis qui a fait une remontée
extraordinaire la route à l'endroit
merci je vous en prie je vous propose de
sciotot 10,1 à vous ainsi que je suis
désolé je ne vais pas me la chasse en
euros 1500 euros et c'est une belle
somme la cendre ariane sandra et ryan
saffré 750 euros pour sandra et 750
euros pour les dans les hôpitaux
c'est ça et de france attend il dire est
qu'on me reste combien et rallye fait
boîte
il reste dix mille euros 1000 euros et
fait fondre tu vois en vrai là on repose
tout repose sur les 10000 euros
parce que parce que sinon sa proposition
est quand même l eau qu elle est au
dessus faut penser aux hôpitaux après
c'est à vous que moi aussi je suis
joueur j'aimerais bien fêté les dix
maires un beau projet on s'arrête au pas
ça n'est pas dû à l'évasion côté tony
dileo continue aux côtés du bout mon
merzouki on viendra peut-être tout alors
offert une dernière proposition allait
tony on enlève trois nouvelles boîtes il
est à 5 à 3 à la 11 l'a8 et l'addition
va aller chercher cette boîte à 10000
euros pour les hôpitaux et pour sandra
et pour tony hale et toni toné sans
marion des fois contre toulouse juste
qu'on pense l'a10 l'a10 pas mal l'a8
aussi je la sentais bien
alors pour délit contre la gestion de la
dysphasie
la vie l'a 10 c'est géraldine maillet
aller là on rentre dans le dur les
cherry jones
olala ça m'énerve parce que ça ça me
touche
vous enlevez la babouche de lui oui vous
perdez la babouche droit allez on y va
on est pas mal du tout là alors il va
tonye tonye depuis que tony est arrivé
on enchaîne les bonnes boîtes région
alemanno qui s'opposent lives non non
non ils sont en baladant si tu ne sens
pas 8 c'est un lieu pérenne c'est un bon
portrait et puis si on est sûr c'est que
si ils restent là 5 à 3 l'amour allez
moto noire d'accra à descendre et on a
trois
l'a3 matthieu delormeau aller la croix
avec matthieu delormeau j'espère que
s'arrête où la centrale vapeur ou la
boîte de pois chiches
koné
tél
oui
la centrale vapeur
ça se passe très très bien depuis
quelques temps j'avais eu un coup de mou
et la serre par un hymne à lesmo suri
allez allez l'a7 well as fait et on a
pas il nous reste qu'à cinq là on
voulait me la haye à 5 à l'hérésie là
c'est la date est là elle est chéri si
on enlève la boîte de pois chiches là
franchement on est ouais franchement je
fais une statue pour tenir
ah oui la joue
est-ce qu'il ya la boîte de poids dessus
là dedans
tous viennent grosses sommes qui a
choisi la 5 je la donne chaud lisieux
l'adorent quoi tu vis de l'assaut s'il a
choisi la c alors moi moi moi je ne sais
pas ce qu'il a dans les bois douilles
on va avoir merzoug blanchard qui va
nous faire une proposition juste après
avoir ouvert la 5 mai dans la fin car
fois dacquois dans la 5
on va toujours chercher où les 500 euros
6 et on va essayer d'enlever cette boîte
de choix qu'il faut se retrouve
maintenant dans deux minutes c'est très
très court on se retrouve juste après et
on va voir avec combien vont repartir
sans gras et et tony et bien sûr ryan
hooker sommes aux hôpitaux de paris sont
si le français pas pour soi montréal il
le sait il est la relation pour la bonne
cause comme d'habitude mon chéri a tout
de suite le changement dans deux minutes
c'est très pratique si vous nous
rejoignez on est en direct qui restait
une boîte à 10 millions une boîte à
lille une boîte à 500 et reste une boîte
de pois chiches vous avez choisi avant
la pause la boîte numéro 5 avec jabel
morini-bosc dessus
on espère que ça va être du torchis la
boiboite de pois chiche que c'est
l'anniversaire de ryan aujourd'hui
attiches comme ça qu'a choisi la route
et rien choisi la boîte numéro 5
on va dire on va dire que ces personnes
on va dire on va dire que bon on va dire
que ces personnes on va dire que ces
personnes parce que j'ai très envie de
faire gagner
sandra tony et ryan mais là j'ai pas des
bonnes nouvelles
non non je fais pas des monnaies j'ai
pas des bonnes nouvelles le chien
malheureuse at on attends attends
attends attends on a chaud s'est passé
on vient de perdre la boîte à cugnaux
isabelle mans ibos ma chérie c'était la
boîte à 10000 euros allez on a une
proposition de mr ou mme blanchard notre
banquier les orques notre charcutier
traders merzouk fait une proposition
sachant qu'il reste la boîte à 1000
euros la boîte à cinq sens et la boisse
de pois chiches alors j'ai une
proposition à vous faire est la suivante
750 euros 750 euros tout de suite où il
reste trois boîtes et ont dit on va
chercher les 1000 euros
c'est une belle proposition qui vous
fait parce qu'ils enlèvent la boîte de
pois chiches et se dit fais une femme
moyenne entre la 500 et la nuit moi je
pense que le plus injuste de le prendre
mon message c'est bien prendre son tu
vois on pensait on pense vraiment tu
vois aux hôpitaux et à vous attend dans
le concret sur les avoir eu l'appui ils
fondèrent vous qu'elle est de 750 euros
vous gardez 750 euros les gars savent
pas quand même de l'enlever cette boîte
de poissy
où les palans lui pense qu'on peut les
avoir quand même les militaires et les
squares et ce trois mois tu là je sais
pas
[Musique]
tu veux non non non tu sais quoi de
maintenant si c'est mon côté joueurs
sandra sandra et tony c'est ça ou vous
prenez la boîte vous prenez la boîte
numéro 4 nous dit on continue bien vous
du temps on prend la proposition de mr
bout de l'enfer à 750 euros
allez on fait quoi tampa bay non c'est
quoi l'affairé bons rails avant moi j'ai
envie de continuer mais attendait
toujours ça pour tu vois les hôpitaux
c'est sérieux deux chances sur trois
c'est ça c'est une chance d'avoir une
belle somme
bon c'est en août et voilà on essaye au
décrochage et ouais c'est pas alors
allez qu'est ce que vous faites moi je
vendrais probablement 20 sites ont aidés
pour 50 euros 750 euros ce qui ferait 7
375 euros pour sandra et thoniers 375
euros pour les objets dont on est sûr de
sa tournée sur moi je suis sur un an
selon déçu on est sûr et ça y est la
décision était prise c'est terminé on
vous offre donc 750 euros donc à
partager avec les autres paris et ho qui
te prend voilà les chéris danser c'est
l'élève de la sorte on va voir ce qu
avait dans la dans la boîte numéro 4
parce que vous avez pigé de savoir les
chérir la bastille vers au ch que vous
avez choisi et ouais ryan voulait
continuer ryan voulait continuer et ryan
avait les millions
oh mais c'est pas grave 50 euros il y
avait les 1000 euros mais vous avez pris
750 euros les cherry a partagé avec les
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
bravo et bravo à cendras bravo à tony je
vous fais de gros bisous et je vous aime
fort merci d'avoir été avec nous